If you've ever seen a dog, you'll
recognize this scenario. A dog finds the
most disgusting puddle on the entire
street, green, murky, sitting there
since Tuesday. And before you can say
anything, it's already drinking it. Head
down, tail up, completely committed. And
then,
nothing happens. The dog is fine, wags
its tail, trots off, probably licks your
face in 20 minutes or so. Meanwhile, if
you drank that same water, you'd be in
bed for a week. So, what's going on? How
do animals drink water that would
destroy a human and then just walk it
off?
The answer isn't a single thing. It's a
whole system, stacked layer on layer,
built over millions of years of
evolution. And it doesn't just apply to
your dog, it applies to almost every
animal on the planet, from cats to
horses to wolves to wild boar. Once you
understand how it works, you'll never
look at a muddy puddle the same way
again.
Before we get into the biology, let's
clear something up, because the premise
of the video is actually a little
misleading, and intentionally so.
Animals do get sick from dirty water all
the time. In the wild, contaminated
water sources kill animals regularly.
They get infections, they weaken,
sometimes they die. The reason we don't
think about this is simple. When an
animal gets seriously ill, it hides.
Crawls into undergrowth, stays out of
sight, and either recover or doesn't.
You never see it. So, when you watch a
lion drink from a swamp and stroll away
looking magnificent, you're not seeing
the full picture. You're seeing a
survivor. The animal that drank from
that same swamp and died are already
gone.
But, and this is the important part,
animals do survive these encounters far,
far more often than we would. And the
reasons why are genuinely remarkable.
The first line of defense is something
that we share with animals, but in a
very different strength.
Stomach acid. Your stomach produces acid
to break down food and kill bacteria. On
the pH scale, where the lower means more
acidic, human stomach acid typically
sits between 1.5 and 3.5. And that
sounds pretty strong, but dogs
consistently measure between pH 1 and pH
1.5. That's up to 10 times more acidic
than ours. To put that in perspective,
the acid in a dog's stomach is strong
enough to dissolve bone. And it's one of
the reasons dogs can eat raw meat that
would hospitalize us.
Any bacteria that makes it past the
mouth and down into that environment
encounters conditions so extreme that
most pathogens simply cannot survive it.
The stomach is essentially a kill
chamber, a filter. And for cats and
dogs, that filter is running at a level
of intensity that we can barely imagine.
And there's another factor on top of
that, speed. Dogs and cats have
relatively short digestive tracts
compared to many other animals.
Food and everything in it moves through
quickly. That matters because bacteria
need time to colonize. In a human gut,
food can sit around long enough for
harmful bacteria to multiply and cause
trouble. In a dog, that window is much,
much shorter. The system is built for
throughput. And here's something that
doesn't get talked about enough, saliva.
Dog saliva isn't just water and enzymes
for digestion. It's an active
antimicrobial environment. It contains
lysozyme, an enzyme that physically
ruptures the cell walls of the bacteria.
Lactoferrin, a protein that binds to
iron.
Since bacteria need iron to survive, it
essentially starves them. Peroxidase,
another antibacterial enzyme. And
immunoglobulins, which are antibodies
doing active patrol duty in the mouth.
So, even before that dirty water reaches
the stomach, it's already being
processed. Not perfectly. Dog saliva
still carries plenty of bacteria and so
but it's a real defensive layer.
Cats have a very similar setup, which is
actually part of why they groom so
obsessively. Every time a cat licks
itself, it's applying a mild
antimicrobial wash. The grooming isn't
just about cleanliness in the way that
we think of it. It's biological
maintenance. And horses, interestingly,
produce large quantities of saliva when
they eat, up to 10 L a day. That
continuous flow helps dilute and
neutralize incoming pathogens before
they reach the stomach.
Now we get to what is probably the most
fascinating part of this whole story.
Inside every animal's gut lives an
enormous ecosystem of microorganisms.
Billions of bacteria, fungi, and other
microbes that have evolved alongside
that animal over its entire lifetime.
This is called the microbiome.
And in a healthy animal, it functions
like a standing army. When a dog
regularly drinks from the same stream or
the same puddle in the same park,
something important happens over time.
The gut microbiome and immune system
adapt to the specific bacteria in that
water. They learn it. The body
essentially says, "Hey, I've encountered
this before. I have a response ready."
This is why a wild animal drinking from
a source it's used to is in a very
different position from one that
suddenly drinks from somewhere new.
Familiar bacteria, even potentially
harmful ones, trigger a calibrated
immune response. Completely novel
pathogens, the ones that the system has
never cataloged, are where things can go
wrong.
It's not immunity, it's familiarity.
And it's built through exposure over
time.
This is also, by the way, why it's not a
great idea to suddenly let a domestic
pet that spent its lifetime drinking
filtered tap water to start casually
drinking from unknown outdoor sources.
Their microbiome may simply not be
primed the same way a dog that has grown
up outside would be.
So far, we've talked mostly about
carnivores, animals with savage stomach
acid and fast digestive systems. But
horses, for instance, are herbivores,
and their entire digestive architecture
is different. So how do they fit into
this?
Horses are what's called hindgut
fermenters. Most of that digestion
doesn't happen in the stomach. It
happens in a massive fermentation
chamber called the cecum and the large
intestine. In a full-size horse, the
gastrointestinal tract can hold over 200
L of content. The cecum holds around 30.
Inside that system lives one of the most
diverse and dense microbial communities
in the animal kingdom. Thousands of
different bacterial species, all
competing, all established, all adapted
to that horse's specific diet and
environment.
When a horse drinks from a river or a
trough and takes in some unwanted
bacteria, those pathogens don't land in
a vacuum. They land in the middle of a
vast, thriving ecosystem that's already
claimed every available niche. The
existing community outcompetes them by
just simply existing. It's a completely
different defense strategy from a dog's
acid chamber, but it works. The scale
and diversity of what's already
happening in there acts as a biological
fortress.
The flip side of this is that horses are
extremely sensitive to disruptions.
Sudden diet changes, stress, antibiotics
can destabilize that ecosystem and cause
serious illness. The same mechanism that
protects them is also their
vulnerability, which is why horse owners
and vets treat gut health with enormous
care.
So, why can't we do any of this?
Fair question, and the honest answer is
we used to be somewhat better at it. For
most of human history, clean treated
water didn't exist. People drank from
rivers, wells, and streams.
Water-borne diseases was one of the
leading causes of deaths throughout
history. But plenty of people also
survived. And there's evidence that
populations with long-term exposure to
local water sources developed
microbiomes that offered some degree of
tolerance. But here's the key
difference. Humans solved dirty water
problem from a different way.
We invent fire, cooking, and eventually
water treatment. We externalized the
filtration instead of evolving a gut
that could handle contamination. We
removed the contamination before it
reached us.
That worked extraordinarily well.
Clean water infrastructure is one of the
greatest public health achievements in
all of human history. It has saved
hundreds of millions of lives. But the
trade-off is that our bodies are now
calibrated for cleanliness. Our stomach
acid is less aggressive, partly because
we cook food, which kills pathogens
before we even swallow.
Microbiomes are less hardened because
we've reduced their exposure.
We've optimized for a different kind of
life. And that optimization is
permanent. We didn't lose the ability to
handle dirty water because we got weak,
we redirected the effort. The dog
evolved a kill chamber in its stomach.
We built water treatment plants.
Different solutions to the same problem.
And honestly, our scale's better.
So the next time your dog dunks its face
into something that looks like it should
be illegal, remember what's actually
happening. The saliva hits first, a
chemical barrier armed with enzymes and
antibodies. And whatever survives that
drops into a stomach so acidic that it
dissolves bone.
Anything still standing then enters a
digestive tract moving fast enough to
deny bacteria time to settle. And all of
that sits on top of a lifetime of
microbial exposure that has tuned the
immune system specifically to handle
whatever lives in that dog's local
environment. It's not one defense, it's
five defenses layered on top of each
other, refined over millions of years of
eating questionable thing.
Animals aren't immune to dirty water,
they're adapted to it.
There's the difference. And that puddle
your dog just drank from, from its
perspective, genuinely not even a
challenge.